hello
we'll wait for a little bit for a few
people to come in here
you guys know i love freedom but
you know as they say freedom is under
attack freedom isn't free
you know all those general purpose
slogans about freedom
so we're going to have a little
conversation about freedom
and we're going to announce our little
discount
and yeah that's what we're gonna gonna
do today
um yeah
let's let's give it at least let's play
for at least 20 people i'm wearing a
freedom shirt right now
what do y'all think i'm keeping this
freedom shirt so actually we're gonna
make it 18
uh freedom shirts for freedom
not 19. it was originally 19 but i'm
wearing this one i'm not going to give
you the one i wore i wouldn't do that
uh yeah right this is the most limited
edition
common merch ever to drop and can we
make them tighter yeah
so that's kind of the problem of course
i'll work out bro
gotta work out you gotta be jacked uh
yeah yeah freedom shirts right
no no if you purchased it a week ago
you can't get the shirt you got to buy a
new one and
no tolerance on this if you try to like
do some crap like i'm going to return it
or i'm going to cancel my order you
don't get a freedom shirt
because freedom isn't free um
are they legal in communist countries
i don't think we ship to venezuela i
don't think so i don't think so
uh are they legal in uh uh you know okay
let's uh talk about freedom okay so
a few things um we made some changes to
the discord
freedom does not mean anarchy
freedom does not mean that everybody can
do whatever they want whenever they want
this leads to a
terrible society this leads to a
terrible community
so we're uh you know we're going to
crack down a bit on the discord
um you know just against general like
[ __ ] posting derailment low quality
comments
if it's a high quality community and
we're going to make it that way
um no anarchy doesn't mean freedom at
all
anarchy just means that the tyranny you
don't get to choose who enforces the
tyranny
anarchy just means that any any you know
joe schmo with a gun can can
can be your uh your lord
uh so yeah i mean you know this is
important it's an important time to have
discussions like this about freedom
uh if you guys don't know i really love
freedom
i really do i really do um you know
okay so the other thing we're going to
talk about
is i know the last stream we talked
about hiring
and we get a lot of emails from people
who are like hey bro i know i'm not
qualified but i'm willing to work for
free you're not working for free
you're asking us to educate you for free
if you
genuinely wanted to work for free and
some people do and we love these people
they're sending pull requests on our
github to openpilot
you can work for free all you want right
but if you're asking to come to this
office
and you want to work for free what
you're doing is you're lowering the bar
in the office right is that what you'd
be doing
i like every person we hire here i
really want them to bring up the bar
which means that every person every new
person we hire has to be better
than the current average at comma and
that's how you get a a community
a country a world
that's uh continually improving uh
because if you're hiring people who are
worse than the average
your your your community your company
your whatever is declining
uh and you know
uh i don't know anything about amazon
leadership principles
um but yeah so we're cracking down
against you know general
uh junk in the discord too this is a
high quality developer community
um that's what our products are too
right our products are all development
kits
uh if if you come in with
the mentality that you're a consumer
that you
join the comma community intending to
extract value to extract
more value than you give back the
problem with that
is um well
you know if everybody comes in with that
mentality it's not a very nice community
it's not one you want to be in either
there's that really great post about
about subcultures
and how to make sure they don't decline
uh so yeah hopefully everybody
understands you know you just got a
there's a big conversation being had now
about content moderation on the internet
and
you you you empathize a whole lot more
the people who have to make the
decisions
um so i mean with the comic community i
hope there's there's there's no
questions it's not a community for
general socialization it's not a
community for [ __ ] talking
it's community for discussion about
common products and common software and
improving them
and kind of your status in that
community
and we're going to make this more
explicit is
have you submitted pull requests have
you submitted code have you
improved other people's lives uh in that
community
and you're giving back you know give
back to the community right or you know
get the
get the boot just purchasing a product
purchasing a product entitles you to
that piece of hardware
it doesn't um and we're gonna make this
clear as well look
if our hardware is broken like the
hardware is broken like we shipped you
something that's broken
this is absolutely our problem uh and
we want to uh fix that
um if the problem is that you can't
figure out how to use the product
that's a problem with you and this is
why we have the the uh the 30
day money back guarantee okay
uh now that that stuff's out of the way
of course i hire people smarter than me
i'd love to hire people smarter we got
to bring the bar up am i the smartest
guy coming hell no
um no no i think i think better
marketing is
in a way exactly the problem right um
one of uh one of my co-workers brought
up at lunch today that if your wendy's
are in and out
right the only things you're competing
on basically your customer support
you're not competing on burgers
we're competing on a technical product
we're competing based on the quality
of our level two driving system compared
to other people's right
another thing that i think a lot of
people don't get about comma
is this is the company mission
solve self-driving cars while delivering
shippable intermediaries
right it's not to continually make more
money
we need to make enough money in order to
accomplish that goal
but money doesn't necessarily you know
having more money doesn't necessarily
help you with that goal it may
even hurt you um so our goal is to keep
you know
profits basically to the point where
we're covering expenses uh which we have
for the whole year
uh going beyond that we don't care we're
not trying to expand this community to
everybody
if you don't have what it takes to you
know not even what it takes you know
what i shouldn't say that because it's
not really a skill-based thing it's a
mentality-based thing
if you come into the it doesn't matter
what skill you have
maybe self-awareness you need
self-awareness but other than that
it's not like you have to be like some
you know 10 years of experienced
programmer or anything like that this is
for joining the community not
coming to work here um but you have to
have an expectation that you're not
going you're not there to consume
product
banned from reddit um you're there to to
to join a community where you're a
fellow developer right you're buying a
development kit
if you're just here to to take i want an
experience i want an experience
there's a hundred thousand other
companies that are out there
begging to cater to you and all they
want from you is their money
um we're not one of those so you know
that's what it is
that said i'm going to change it we're
going to change it now to
to only uh to only
let's say we do want your money it's not
that we don't want your money and we
certainly appreciate our consumers
our customers but not if um
you know they're there to demand more
than what they purchased right
uh okay so we're gonna limit the number
of times this can be used we're gonna
change it to 18.
the discount code goes live tomorrow
on july 4th ah
and the discount code is freedom shirt
so you will get a free freedom shirt
with your comma 2 purchase
if you purchase it tomorrow freedom
shirt
i will show you some of the freedom
shirts um you can put
in the description make sure to get your
order in as close to
uh midnight as possible
these are the sizes that we have of the
freedom shirts
um you can see we have many freedom
shirts in this freedom shirt bucket
there's a lot of freedom in here
so much freedom so much freedom
so much freedom so much freedom so
much freedom here in the freedom shirt
box um now
you asked george why aren't you doing a
discount on comma twos
uh i'm wearing a medium right now this
is a medium
uh so yeah they run a little bit small
uh you can really see my uh
chest uh so we're not discounting we're
not just counting comma twos period
uh we've never done a discount on the
comma two um and
i'll tell you the truth why this is the
comma two production facility
this the bins marked past
are all the comma twos that we have
uh so we have about 58 comma twos and
then we have these ones up here testing
see the green ones passed red ones
failed notice why these ones failed
cpu temperature too hot so we fixed a
lot of the heat issues
by screening out uh
well this has been true for a while
uh so yeah that's why
uh that's why there's no discount on the
common twos when there was eons
uh we had many many eons in stock you
know we had we had boxes and boxes of
eons
and of course i wanted to you know move
that product right now
if you guys order a hundred comma twos
tomorrow
yeah but i'm wearing the freedom shirt
you wanna say hi to the the the
youtubers
uh yeah um sliding oh oh
yeah yeah check out the freedom shirt
man i think i look good in the freedom
chair
uh yeah there's 18 freedom shirts
because this is 19.
i stole a freedom shirt two women's
largest
seven smalls oh it's a women's more
mediums
wait the weapons larger the same size
i'm wearing a medium
yeah this is a compression shirt for
working out yeah it's for working out it
makes your muscles look big when you
look in the mirror
you do like that yeah you know what i'm
saying i like the arm comma
yeah arm comma this is this is the most
exclusive merch
honestly you guys there's 18 of these
in the world so you better get your
order in at midnight tonight that's
midnight pdt
i'll show you what i set it to in
shopify and i swear i'm not going to
change it
so i don't know what time this actually
is in your time zone
but yeah freedom shirt
yeah um i think we're going to limit it
to one use per customer
you know one freedom shirt per customer
you don't need more freedom shirts than
one
don't be greedy with the freedom there's
plenty of freedom for everybody
what no there's only there's only 18. it
is a limited supply that's true
you're gonna flip it on ebay for profit
yeah so it only comes with a comma two
you use the code freedom shirt a check
out tomorrow
starting and i already said if anyone's
like oh i want to return it so i can get
a freedom shirt
no well you can buy it tomorrow
but if you cancel an order and then you
try to add freedom shirt later
you don't get a freedom shirt it's so
hard if you're trying to pull some [ __ ]
no freedom shirts for you
oh you want to tell them about discord i
was talking a little bit about discord
yeah
uh did you talk to them about working
for free i did talk to them about
working for free and i talked to them
how actually it's kind of disrespectful
because what you're actually doing is
you're asking us to educate you for free
and if you want me to educate you look
up what harvard charges i charge double
[Laughter]
i think it's twice the education it's
twice the education exactly for twice
the price that's right
um so that's what if you want to come to
comma and be educated
you pay us 100k a year two people
organically submit speed tests and those
are our favorites yes
if you just go out there and find our
programming challenge
you're great you know what else if you
submit if you contribute
dean lee special shout out to dean lee
doesn't join the discord just submits
pull requests on github see that's the
kind of contribution we like you want to
work for us
for free do that don't send an email
saying you want to work for us for
just go work bro you're asking me to
manage you for free is that what you're
asking
people want permission oh people want
permission tell them how life works
i mean i don't know how does life work
you're gonna be in the frame you got to
be in the frame here
you're going to take a chair welcome to
the chat to chats with the executive
team at kama ai
i'm working on a culture post yeah yeah
we're going to talk to you all about
culture tell them about our lunch chat
today
our lunch chat today was how much the
discord sucks and how we're going to
remove a lot of the low quality [ __ ]
from it
well i think people don't understand
where we are in our cycle
as a company i don't know anything about
cycles we're not a corporation
that's right we're never going to be a
corporation that's right
the customer can be wrong i think
i think people just aren't used to being
told that
i mean look we like our customers
they're
yeah i mean you know what yeah actually
that's not true whether the customer is
wrong or right we judge you by nature's
standards
whatever nature's standards are right
have we considered becoming a non-profit
we're not a non-profit company so
in a way we're really not that
dissimilar from every other
tech startup out there right a lot of
tech startups brag about being
pre-revenue
honestly i'd rather get money from
committed users who want to help develop
who want to join
look you say it all the time we're
incredibly open i love being open with
you guys
i'm more open with you than i am with
vcs i think a lot of these keys are
scummier than a lot of you
um but the flip side of that
is where technically i mean in a lot of
ways we're a pre-revenue startup
commons multi-billion dollar exit
doesn't come from us selling a comma 2
to you
it's a laughable amount of money it
comes from us solving self-driving cars
which is our mission right
yeah we're just trying to solve
self-driving cars we're not trying to
yeah build a massive corporation no
we're not trying to build a consumer i
mean we sell these products as dev kits
basically
just so people who want to come develop
with our stuff have an easy way to enter
the ecosystem
you know you don't have to pay us a
dollar you can figure out how to build
all of comma stuff all the stuff you
need is posted online for free if you
know how to find it right
that's a big part of it yeah the comma 2
is not free but you can go you can build
a neo board which for the most part
still
works you can buy the cheapest phone off
ebay
you can 3d print your own case right if
you want to join this this this
ecosystem you can join it for nothing
but if you want it to be easy and nice
well by cover two right
um now if you want support that's easy
and nice
well it's a lot easier yeah sure for the
most part if you buy
if you buy a coma too and you don't have
any unrealistic expectations like a
torque mod for your honda
you can have a good time i think it is
about managing expectations and we're
working on doing that a little bit
better
the bar used to be a lot higher it's
moved a little bit and we're gonna
continue to try to talk more about what
is what a good community member looks
like
a whole lot of uh look if you um
purchase a comma two and you never send
us a support request
and you figure out how to do everything
you're good we like you
right if you expect support if you
expect to be treated a certain way
you shouldn't buy the product from us
right
i agree yeah i think it's pretty clear
but the flip side of that
and like why i feel okay saying all this
is because
well if you have a problem with
autopilot you don't have to rely on us
you can rely on yourself you know it's
open source right and that's the beauty
of open source
it's very unfair if a company says
there's no support
and if it doesn't work get [ __ ]
right we don't say that we don't say
that we say there's no support if it
doesn't work
you have access to most of the same
stuff we have access to almost
everything
this is also why we have a one-year
warranty on the hardware the hardware is
not open source
but we warranty it we make sure it'll
work if there's any actual defects in
the hardware
we will fix them we'll really try to do
a great job with that if there's a
problem with the software or if there's
a problem with you figuring out how to
use the software let's open the source
bros
you showed them all the testing we're
doing yeah yeah you want to
go show up some testing uh if i call
comedy i support there is no comment i
support
somebody asked for our phone number uh
and we laughed at them
i mean there's an email there's an email
supporter comma ai but most of what
supported comma ai will tell you is
if it's a hardware defect we'll look
into it otherwise
fix the software yourself we have a 30
day money back guarantee
yeah i think that's pretty clear olympus
really have much more to say about that
yeah uh oh yeah no we've been working
really hard look
now there's some talk about well why
don't you like gate it why don't you
make people like do a programming test
for them to be able to buy stuff
like we don't want to add artificial
difficulty to this right
very talented you know programmers or
people who want in the community are
busy they shouldn't have to
it shouldn't mean that they shouldn't
have a good experience we want to make
the experience
as good as possible right but think of
the experience more like maybe the hard
part of the experience not the soft part
of the experience oh dartmouth says
maybe we should change our email to
hardware support and comment
it's not a bad idea yeah yeah
i think that does make it a little bit
more clear yeah because we only said
yeah because we only sell hardware
yeah yeah maybe we'll do that yeah
there's lots of people on discord who
are very helpful and i would i don't
know
how much you've said but we're really
grateful to our moderators and people
who help
everybody in discord there's a lot thank
you yeah yeah there's a lot of great
people
great content in the discord we really
you know by getting rid of all the
less good stuff we really it's to let
them shine more than anything else you
know
yeah yeah uh
yeah order support yeah but order like
people think they're entitled to support
for open pilot they're not
why do you think they think that
um
i mean because you know they didn't
really like look into what it was they
just like
you know type they custom software they
just followed some tutorial they read
online not put out by us
um and then in that case you might ask
them for support right
oh yeah if you ordered a bosch harness
and you received an idec absolutely
we had three three people this week
there was uh i heard there was one
yeah one of our contractors messed up
swapped them out we shouldn't even we
didn't even make them send it back we
just sent them free we sent them new
ones
we're seven free new ones thank you yes
yeah see i mean that's the right way we
deal with that right
uh what percent of emails are crap um we
do ignore stupid emails i mean we do our
best to ignore everything but there's a
lot of inbound and we're very small team
so
we're continuing trying to just stop the
top of the funnel from being so big
yeah um
make a helpline for the software didn't
you know about the nintendo power
hotline back in the day
should we charge two dollars a minute
for open files is this like uh
the hotline just imagine you purchased
super mario 3
and you couldn't get past the the third
level in the fourth world
do you think you can call nintendo and
ask for support
we're just not there yet but we're never
going to be there
we still have kids today we sell dev
kits always going to sell that i think
it's clear what you get
dev stands for developer in case
anyone's confused about that
maybe they thought it stood for
something else yeah
duh dev lots of support
i don't know man if you're not a
developer we don't recommend you buy
this product that's right
that's right but that being said like i
really don't want to exclude people
because they think that like i don't
know how to program right you don't have
to know how to program
no you should be patient you're willing
to learn willing to learn that's it i
know we ask
self self awareness self aware self
awareness
really important yeah snaps for self
awareness
software support with prime subscription
and why does everybody
what support does everybody need so they
don't want support you see
they they get it and then like their
honda doesn't have enough torque so they
want the torque mod
right which is super dangerous by the
way
safety is very important guys which is
very important um that's one of our main
issues in the discord well you know
they're they're
just lots of like
yeah cool you take them back there
uh yeah yeah we took them back there
briefly are there secrets
no i get nervous taking showing people
around back there yeah
we've gotta show them around a little
bit more uh and then we'll do one more
pull for the freedom shirt
categories for aircraft wait a poll
what you say polar pole what is that
pole a pole
no just a shell uh-huh a pole george
wants people to work for free
whoa no i i have we ever said we want
people to work for free well people
email
us and say hey i know i'm not qualified
for this job but i'm willing to work for
free
and like you understand that that costs
us as a company more than we gain
i mean i'll come a pencil yeah people
who are
free you know we love commonplace we
were talking about how comma pencil is
one of the nicest channels on discord
yeah literally it's really nice people
are contributing doing great work
yeah we're sending out eric b and pj lau
are going to get free comma twos
when we uh i mean i think they've been
the biggest two contributors maybe some
of the other people who've been
contributing give them like 100 bucks
off or something
we are going to do um maybe some new
merch
we've heard we're out of shape what's
left yeah yeah we'll send we'll send
things out to people here
here's every time you contribute
something you go up every time you know
you say something stupid or you ask for
support you go down
i also think it's important i think it's
important not to have that karma
i think there's um expectations
are challenging yeah don't have
expectations
don't have expectations that's right
under promise over perform
we are here to under promise the [ __ ]
out of all you that's right you won't
get
anything you'll send us money and we
won't send you anything
that's a lot we really try to come up
every monday and tuesday
you guys something is going to happen
with the common points oh something
yeah i'm very excited
i think we can tell them the word it
doesn't mean anything epot bros
you heard of epcot get ready for the
epod
chart are you leaking it's not leaking
it's just that pot it doesn't mean
anything
i mean they can do google does epoch
mean something if you google it
no way they know where it's derived from
yeah
they'll never figure it out man they'll
never figure it out
uh it's a comment is it a rash guard
what no it's is this a rashford cards
are for
them you know it's just like who bought
these
who knows man just in case this was an
ambitious
former comma employee project
um let's see
my battery is dying wait i love this on
the label did you show them
what they show on the label it says made
in the usa
freedom reading i can't read it's
backwards it says seven days no training
makes one week
that's right
that's that we comma phone you know
performance fabric
all right i'm gonna show them the back a
little and then yeah chill for how you
can get a freedom shirt
you're not on a gimbal you're sitting on
the table sorry do we even have a gimbal
we had one i don't know where it is can
i buy a coma to a dogecoin
i mean you can convert your dogecoin to
cash and then buy a comma too that's
right
pet name for common customers is comp i
don't think we've ever comma
comma discuss scopies with stuff but
periscope died
george you're out to scam us we want
comma
oh the coveralls were the best you feel
skinny good
maybe we'll do a special edition
coverall um
they're expensive though can you use a
combi 2 with a ford i don't know man
a comma 2 is just hardware we sell you
hardware can you use it with a
television maybe
i don't know comma boxers
george couldn't hack a ford
uh the commenters are like it's like
discord in here
no they're pretty bad can i use common
russia you can use it anywhere there's
roads i think
oh the freedom shirt's free free shirt
is free
all right guys i'm gonna put my mask on
when you buy a comma too
wait why are you putting your mask on
you know it's important to be safe from
coronavirus i'm worried about some of
those people in discord giving me
clanovirus
i'm within six feet of them you know
all right we're going all right we're
going
you want to switch flip the camera have
you got one you can you can hold camera
no you're better at it than me it's
unclear well i don't know
um yeah the secrets i'll show you you
can show them this you know guys the
data
is growing the data center is growing
yeah the models are getting huge
yeah just just this
oh this is good george is using a mask
because we're toxic
[Laughter]
uh yeah welcome to the production we
just
we just reorganized all the shelving
uh really ramping up production but yeah
the reason there's no sale is because
there's not enough common tools to
support a sale
common tools are rare they're selling so
fast so fast
oh thanks guys this is how we manage and
measure our yields every week here's our
past bin
and our failure what we have right now
it's gone it's only like 50 here
yeah yeah that's a really low number
these are from our 3d printers also
we're looking
no we're not moving production to uh
china anytime soon we produce
can we meet production guy no no no no
no we're not we're not we're not doing
it
you guys can see the team
beautiful
flash and uno boards
oh man
do they know we do a really thorough
testing yeah
gotta get that success one off here damn
look at the back
you guys can see virtually chris back
here
also if you're interested we got stacks
of ups's and then we want to buy these
what is oh cyber powers
oh my god what i forgot about that gear
freedom shirts we're giving them away
tomorrow
only tomorrow this is the most exclusive
merchandise
wow you own some of the most exclusive
products wow
yeah i'm keeping this one we have 18
more they're going to be given away to
the first 18 people who buy tomorrow
with code
freedom share tomorrow's in midnight
starting today
yeah pdt yeah yeah don't mess it up
those are great shirts
chase says hi oh my god what's up
all right you know what should we let
unlimited people
use the code freedom share and then only
the first day team will get it
how is that that much different from
just giving 18 out
because the the final people no i guess
i guess well
yeah it doesn't matter
no i think we have a good system going
but there's only 18 freedom shirts then
there was only ever 18. but imagine we
can get people to buy
what if whoa wait no i got an idea
okay no no new plan no serious new plan
this is a better way to
to get money we're gonna you could as
many people as want can use freedom
shirt tomorrow
if you use the code freedom shirt you
enter into the freedom shirt lottery
every comment who you buy enters you
once into the freedom shirt lottery
okay yeah and then we're gonna do dice
to determine which order numbers get
freedom shirts
oh that'll be a great stream oh i love
it uh we're not streaming that no
no no well again i do want to see that
we did the dice fairly but
there's no more usage limits on freedom
share
every comment two you purchase show them
this to make sure people know
you know when it is what it's scheduled
it's not illegal it's a loot box
it's a loot box is it actually legal um
no you can have a you can have a lottery
i believe the lottery is allowed no the
loot boxes really are scanning people
can i show the hyundai sonata i don't
think it's illegal if you don't get a
shirt and you sue
us banned for life we could use some
more high-profile lawsuits
so if we could uh george doesn't have
had enough
high-profile lawsuits in his life so if
um
yeah yeah loot box is not a lottery
that's correct
oh sick well um after viv
genuinely shield for how great this
common merch was i realized how
rare and exclusive freedom shirts are
do we have a request yeah wait they are
very rare
they're very rare no they're not seeing
this yummy sonata
why would we entertain that request you
want to see your comments
to your local hyundai dealership
these are ultra rare cream shirts they
look so soft
they're pretty nice yeah yeah i'm gonna
put one on later
all right tomorrow we did it
if we only get 18 comma 2 orders
tomorrow everyone gets a freedom shirt
if we get less than 18
everyone gets a freedom shirt you get
more than 18 lottery
sorry loot box whatever the most legal
way to say that
seth says you're looking fit raffle
thanks dad
all right all right i think that's it
all right
uh yeah discord we're really trying to
make everything
higher brow higher brow community uh if
you're here to be a leech
uh don't buy chelsea have you listened
to anything we've said today
if we buy a common tool you show me the
hyundai sonata
part of me says sure but then yeah
you're right you know that they're
already asking me for something
so can they listen to anything we've
said today i guess not
how many more times do we need to say it
yeah
yeah yeah see no part of that's bad
because i would encourage things like
that you know back when we needed money
now we don't need money anymore as much
all right recalling it yeah i think we
called it
yeah oh my god what happens to the car
manufacturers lock the comma twos out
i answer this question all the time why
do why do people think it's going to
happen
they can't keep you out they are aware
that apple and sony couldn't keep me out
right like software companies
do they think that like honda and toyota
can
keep me up bro what did i say last time
that was asked
thug means never having to say you're
sorry i think we ended right create a
wiki for faq i think we did all right
bye bye